[Aplausos]
[Música]
amigos tanzania es noticia por dos
motivos sí sí
tanzania un motivo bueno y uno malo lo
bueno es que este país del este de
áfrica celebra elecciones presidenciales
y parlamentarias el próximo 28 de
octubre unas elecciones que podrían
acabar con el poder de jong full y
presidente del país desde que ganó las
elecciones del 2015 pero la mala noticia
es que su presidencia ha sido todo una
apisonadora para los derechos y
libertades que existían en tanzania
hablamos de violencia extrema contra los
opositores una fuerte represión política
y una libertad de expresión limitada
para todo lo que no sean lo hacía
alabanzas al actual presidente así que
por supuesto tal y como os podéis
imaginar esto es algo que nos hace dudar
de que vayamos a ver algunas elecciones
libres sin que esa mañana de algún otro
modo mientras mago fully esté en el
poder lo siento pero es que en este caso
la verdad es que somos pesimistas y
aunque no conocemos lo que va a pasar en
el futuro próximo nos lo imaginamos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en cualquier caso lo que sí sabemos es
que la inestabilidad política provocada
por mind fool y también ha tenido
consecuencias económicas y ojo que esto
es importantes y puede que alguno de
vosotros estén pensando tanzania pero
que me estás contando enrique venga ya y
que esperabas pues si así es como
piensas lo siento pero ya sabes que un
visor político pues nos gusta ser
optimistas y lo cierto es que en este
caso hubiésemos tenido mucho espero que
muchos motivos para hacerlo amigos en el
siglo 21 arrancó bien para tanzania con
muchos años de fuerte crecimiento
económico el país por así decirlo se
situaba en esa línea del nuevo despertar
africano que ya os hemos contado en
otros vídeos sobre etiopía o ruanda sin
embargo desde la llegada de mou julia al
poder parece que tanzania pues ya no va
tan bien hasta el punto de que el fm y
pone en duda las cifras de crecimiento
económico aportadas por el gobierno así
que en la pregunta de hoy es por qué se
ha deteriorado tanto la situación
política de tanzania están justificadas
las sospechas sobre las cifras ofrecidas
por el gobierno de macul y hoy en visual
político no sé responder a todas estas
preguntas pero antes antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
el socialismo africano
es posible que alguna vez hayáis oído
hablar de lugares como dar es salaam
tanganika off arriba pues os recomiendo
que estéis atentos porque los matices
históricos son muy interesantes fijaos
[Música]
para empezar también es la unión de dos
estados que un día llegaron a ser
independientes tanganika y zanzíbar
tanganika es el nombre de uno de los
lagos más importantes del mundo el lago
tanganika pero cuando nos referimos a la
republica de tanganika estamos hablando
de la actual tanzania continental a la
tanzania situada en áfrica entre el lago
tanganika y el océano índico por su
parte de zanzíbar es un archipiélago de
este mismo océano formado por varias
islas e islotes
amigos hablar de tanzania es hablar de
los grandes exploradores de áfrica en el
interior de este país se produjo el
famoso encuentro entre el henry stanley
y el doctor livingstone pero no era esa
la primera vez que un europeo visitaba
estas tierras por zanzíbar ya bien
estado los europeos siglos atrás hasta
que les echó de sultán de omán por aquel
entonces los omaníes dominaban toda la
costa del índico desde omán hasta
madagascar y hasta tal punto este la
territorio suyo que en el siglo 19 el
sultán trasladó su capital desde omán a
factiva luego que pasa es que sus hijos
pues se llevan peor que messi con
bartoméu así que una rama familiar se
queda una herencia con el sultanato de
sanz iván y no quiso saber nada más de
sus parientes árabes y de esta forma es
como este sultanato fue plenamente
independiente durante algo más de tres
décadas hasta que el imperio británico
pues se hizo con el control por cierto
este sultanato también poseía la costa
de este del continente africano así que
ya os podéis imaginar porque se llama
dar es salaam la ciudad más importante
de tanzania un país ejemplar hasta hace
pocos años en lo que respecta a la
convivencia religiosa pero en el que el
cristianismo tiene una fuerte presencia
a veces incluso exagerada
el líder de tanzania anima a la gente a
rezar en multitudes contra el
coronavirus el presidente
full y desdeña el distanciamiento social
libia jesucristo como un antídoto contra
el virus satánico por su parte la
tanzania continental fue colonizada por
los alemanes y luego se convirtió en un
protectorado británico así fue hasta el
año 1961 el año de la independencia de
tanganika y luego dos años después en
1963 llegó la independencia de francia
pero amigos las situaciones eran muy
pero que muy diferentes
[Aplausos]
mientras las que tengan ica en sus
primeros años fue una república
multipartidista zanzíbar volví a manos
de un sultán y de una poderosa élite
árabe dominante sin embargo el sultanato
independiente de alcívar duró apenas un
mes luego que tardó en estallar una
revolución que depuso inmediatamente
resultante para fundar la república
popular defensiva y como os podéis
imaginar lo de popular no era un
objetivo gratuito después de una
revolución y el país estaba a punto a
puntito de convertirse en el enésimo
experimento hacia el comunismo sin
embargo su presidente
avei karume era un tipo de izquierda así
pero más moderado no quería una
dictadura comunista y dio con la fórmula
para evitar unir sanz y bar con
tanganika para formar un nuevo país
tanzania para ello tuvo que entenderse
con él considerado como padre de la
nación tanzano julius nyerere un
profesor el arquitecto del socialismo
africano que tenía un concepto muy
particular de la democracia la
democracia no es una botella de
coca-cola que se puede importar la
democracia debe desarrollarse según el
país en particular nunca fue un país en
el que hubiera muchos partidos y ya por
eso asumiera que fuese democrático
julius nyerere el caso es que con este
punto de partida tal y como os podéis
imaginar hiere y karume se repartieron
el poder llegar a un acuerdo claro y
conciso ya que sería presidente de
tanzania y karume su vicepresidente
además karume sería también el
presidente franz iba que pasaba a
convertirse en una región semiautónoma
ese era el pacto pero amigos los planes
de gènere para la nueva avanzan ya no se
quedaron ahí y hay que decir que el
resultado pues no fue muy diferente de
lo que se había planteado para sanz iván
aunque eso sí tal y como había prometido
sin alinearse con la unión soviética
[Música]
el socialismo africano marcó las dos
primeras décadas de tanzania nyerere
declaró un estado de partido único
nacional hizo empresas y fábricas y
obligó a 11 millones de campesinos a
trabajar en granjas colectivas por la
fuerza quemando sus casas para evitar
que regresaran a ellas por supuesto
estas granjas fueron un completo fracaso
el resultado fue una hambruna masiva y
el cause económico a pesar del enorme
potencial de tanzania
[Música]
en aquel momento los préstamos del fondo
monetariointernacional ayudaron al país
a salir de aquella situación pero el
fondo puso condiciones y por una vez no
pidieron nada particularmente
controvertido el país básicamente ante
todo tenía que habilitar libre mercado
un cambio que genere por supuesto no
quiso asumir así que en 1985 entendido
que su tiempo como presidente se había
terminado con 63 años se jubiló y se fue
a su casa sin duda una de las mejores
decisiones de toda su carrera política
su marcha voluntaria permitió que los
cambios llegaron al país y en 1994 se
restauró la democracia multipartidista
tanzania y amigos desde entonces esta
hazaña se convirtió en uno de los países
favoritos de áfrica para los inversores
a medida que se relajó el control
estatal sobre la economía la inversión
comenzó a llegar tanzania tras
formalmente inversión extranjera directa
por un valor del 4% del pib una cifra
nada desdeñable reino unido y eeuu
fueron durante décadas los principales
inversores hasta que por cierto todo
cambió en los últimos años china emerge
como el principal inversor de tanzania
en cualquier caso en la cuestión es que
toda esta inversión ha tenido
consecuencias la situación económica de
tanzania ha mejorado y su renta per
cápita se ha duplicado lo que va a
decirlo además como podéis ver en este
gráfico el crecimiento anual del
de tanzania no ha parado de crecer y
durante los últimos 20 años ha estado
por encima del 4% anual efectivamente la
economía tanzana se comportaba mejor que
la del áfrica sub sahariana y así
parecía que las cosas iban poco a poco
mejor en un país que quizás estaba
llamado a convertirse en una de las
grandes esperanzas africanas y sabéis
que así fue hasta que mago fuling su
actual presidente llegó al poder porque
amigos
con su llegada todo cambio atentos
[Música]
pudo ser de tanzania
maud fuller es conocido como el
bulldozer un apodo ganado en su época
como ministro de fomento pero lo cierto
es que este mismo adjetivo se lo ha
ganado también durante su etapa como
presidente aunque en este caso por
motivos diferentes algunos mejores y
otros peores por ejemplo estrenó su
presidencia arrasando como un auténtico
bulldozer contra la corrupción retiró de
la nómina pública a 10.000 trabajadores
fantasma trabajadores fantasma que
suponía en cada mes un gasto de 32
millones de dólares para el país luego
otra medida muy celebrada fue integraron
al vino en su gabinete ya que en áfrica
hay muchos prejuicios contra los albinos
y son perseguidos por los hechiceros
locales pero queridos amigos de visual
político no cantes victoria hasta aquí
llegan los aciertos de mago full y en
estos cinco años
[Música]
el presidente de tanzania gobernado a lo
loco sin pensar en las consecuencias de
cada una de sus medidas por ejemplo en
primer lugar propuso que la educación
secundaria fuera gratuita lo que puede
sonar a primera vista muy bien pero sin
embargo la consecuencia inmediata fue
por un lado buena pero por otra
problemática ya que las escuelas se
llenaron y la situación se escapó de
control es fácil prometer algo pero si
no tienes recursos ojo que el remedio
puede ser peor que la enfermedad y eso
no es todo la situación del sistema
educativo tanzano quedó definitivamente
tocada cuando magú juli decreto a nivel
nacional la expulsión de todos los
trabajadores extranjeros sin los
permisos adecuados
esta medida expulsó a miles de keniatas
que ejercían de maestros por lo tanto el
balance final es terrible más alumnos y
menos profesores es decir clases
masificadas y peor calidad de la
enseñanza
luego están sus medidas económicas por
ejemplo el puerto de dar es salaam en
una puerta de entrada al este de áfrica
por aquí circulaban mercancías con
origen y destino a países vecinos del
interior del continente como malawi o
zambia pues bien mouth full y quiso
sacar provecho económico de esta
situación incrementando la presión
fiscal sobre todo este comercio que
consiguió al hacerlo pues que las
empresas navieras cambiarán sus rutas
comerciales y ahora utilicen más los
puertos de kenia claro que esto no es lo
peor porque otros sectores económicos no
han tenido la oportunidad de escapar tan
fácilmente de sus garras
durante los últimos años cualquier
estado de derecho que le otorgue ciertas
garantías a los inversores ha
desaparecido por completo en este país
digamos que los abusos del gobierno de
mago fully contra las empresas
extranjeras no han parado de producirse
hasta el punto de llegar a verse
barbaridades como ésta tanzania se
enfrenta a una empresa minera británica
con una multa equivalente al valor de
dos siglos de sus beneficios si a ver
vale lo sabemos todos la explotación de
los recursos naturales de áfrica siempre
es un tema delicado delicado porque el
beneficio de la riqueza apenas suele
notarse a nivel local pero ahora bien es
que en esta ocasión hablamos de una
multa de agárrate a la silla 190.000
millones de dólares a la compañía
británica acacia miley esto supone ni
más ni menos que cuatro veces el pib de
tanzania y puede que alguno esté
pensando pero bueno y como demonios
justificó el gobierno de maui lo de
poner tantos ceros pues según sus
cálculos 40 mil millones correspondían a
impuestos atrasados y los otros 150.000
tenían que ver con los intereses y bueno
la multa fiscales si acusaban a casa de
declarar menos de un 10 por ciento de
las exportaciones de oro que realizaban
desde tanzania eso sí hay que decir que
la respuesta de la empresa fue genial le
dijeron a mago fully a ver a ver nos
encantaría que vuestra acusación fuese
real
ya que en ese caso estaríamos explotando
las mayores minas de oro del mundo pero
es que no es así así que al final acacia
y tanzania han acordado zanjar todo esto
por 300 millones de dólares mientras
claro los inversores internacionales
después ya han tomado nota
[Música]
la empresa británica petra diamonds ha
puesto en venta su mina de diamantes en
tanzania por acusaciones similares de
evasión fiscal luego las trabas a la
inversión extranjera han afectado
incluso a proyectos interesantes como el
del puerto de maga moi o un mega
proyecto en el que las compañías chinas
implicadas y el fondo soberano inversor
de omán no acaban de ponerse de acuerdo
con el gobierno tanzano o deben de andar
sobrados de capital para poner tantas y
tantas trabas en fin que peligroso es el
populismo de recetas low cost el caso
amigos es que el frenazo que se ha dado
las cifras de inversión debería haber
tenido un impacto notable sobre la
economía tratada sin embargo las cifras
oficiales ofrecidas por el gobierno
mantienen el crecimiento del pib por
encima del 5% no es claro que estos
números no convencen a organismos
internacionales como el banco mundial y
el fmi que sospechan que hace tiempo que
las cosas dejaron de ir bien en este
país no os explican por ejemplo cómo
puede crecer la economía y caer la
recaudación fiscal o los préstamos al
sector privado también han caído cifras
menos técnicas pero muy significativas
como por ejemplo las ventas de la mayor
cervecera del país vamos que ue la
crisis pero vamos
[Música]
y luego está el aparentemente
inexistente efecto de la joven 19 sobre
la economía del país bound full y
declaró hace meses que tanzania estaba
libre de coronavirus claro que noticias
como ésta nos hacen sospechar que no es
así ya no es un delito publicar
estadísticas en tanzania vale la presión
internacional ejercida por el banco
mundial ha conseguido que el gobierno de
mago full ya haya dado marcha atrás a la
legislación aprobada que convertir en
delito publicar estadísticas no
oficiales pero esperad un momento porque
aunque ahora está despenalizado sigue
siendo necesaria la aprobación de la
oficina nacional de estadísticas para
poder publicar cualquier dato no oficial
así que como os podéis imaginar pues la
libertad de expresión no atraviesa por
su mejor momento en tanzania vamos desde
luego que no y ojo porque toda esta
represión también ha llegado hasta la
oposición política de qué manera atentos
el futuro de tanzania
el crecimiento económico de tanzania
desde que abandonó el socialismo
africano y se abre el libre mercado ha
tenido un elemento clave hasta el
momento su estabilidad política nunca se
enfrentó a una guerra civil ni a una
dictadura militar el país se abría el
multipartidismo hace 25 años eso sí
desde entonces el partido gobernante ha
sido el mismo que antes del
multipartidismo el chama cha mapinduzi
yo espero que eso giles se diga así
traducido por cierto quiere decir algo
como partido de la revolución y no me
preguntéis qué revolución porque es el
típico partido que no quiere que cambie
nada y que lo más revolucionario que
tiene es un hombre pero más de uno
seguro que estáis pensando a ver a ver
tampoco es que tanzania fuera antes de
mahou full y muy democráticos y siempre
gobernaba el mismo partido no pero es
que ahora estamos hablando de que un
país con una democracia defectuosa se ha
convertido en esto
tanzania resta el líder del partido de
la oposición y revoca la licencia de un
periódico noticias como ésta del pasado
mes de junio se han convertido en el día
a día de tanzania cierre de periódicos
censura artistas vetados e incluso
arrestados
[Música]
cualquiera que se mueve en contra de
mago félix se pone en el punto de mira
del mundo también en la arena política
por ejemplo se ha prohibido la cobertura
televisiva en directo de los debates
parlamentarios para que no sean visibles
las críticas a mao full y los mítines y
las manifestaciones políticas han sido
también prohibidos las desapariciones de
periodistas críticos y opositores están
a la orden del día y la violencia amigos
ha llegado a niveles inusitados sin ir
más lejos el candidato de la oposición
para las próximas presidenciales
el canario hindú lee soo ha estado tres
años entre kenia y bélgica recuperándose
de las graves secuelas del tiroteo del
que fue víctima un tiroteo por el que
por cierto nadie ha sido detenido aunque
creo que todos podemos imaginar quién
está detrás y precisamente por eso no
regresó a tanzania hasta el pasado mes
de julio su seguridad no está
garantizada y hablamos del principal
candidato de la oposición
y luego otra derivada más toda esta
represión amigos ha espantado los
donantes internacionales reacios claro a
financiar a los caprichos de un
presidente con aires de dictador lanzan
y obligan a buscar financiación para su
presupuesto debido a que la ayuda de los
donantes queda congelada ante semejante
panorama es muy complicado pensar en un
resultado electoral adverso para azul y
hace cinco años se impuso con el 58 por
ciento de los votos el resultado más
ajustado de la breve historia de
tanzania y amigos
sabéis que que ahora parece imposible
que la oposición vaya a tener alguna
oportunidad de ganar las elecciones y es
una auténtica lástima por dos motivos en
primer lugar porque la alternancia
política es buena para consolidar una
democracia especialmente cuando el chama
cha mapinduzi lleva toda la vida en el
poder y en segundo lugar porque hay una
alternativa viable la oposición y de
nada porque además no se ha vuelto
radical no se ha convertido en un
partido desesperado por el dominio del
chama cha mapinduzi y con ganas de
revancha al contrario aparentemente y
siguiendo la estela que ha abierto había
que mete en etiopía el tsc además se
propone combatir la corrupción defiende
planteamientos moderados de
centroderecha y un modelo económico más
liberal algo que no nos engañemos por un
lado le encantaría a los inversores
internacionales y que por otro
y esto lo visto y tal y como están las
cosas le podría venir genial al país
ahora bien un momento porque si la
oposición lo está pasando mal en
tanzania en zanzíbar están aún peor
zanzíbar vive una profunda crisis desde
que hace cinco años se anulase el
resultado de las elecciones regionales
cuando todo indicaba que se produciría
la victoria de la oposición la violenta
represión sufrida por sus partidarios
ejercida por milicias progubernamentales
conocidas como los zombis está
radicalizando la situación el frente
cívico unido una fuerza moderada antaño
aspirante a cogobernar tanzania con la
fuerza dominante en tanganika está
siendo empujada a defender el derecho de
autodeterminación del archipiélago de
zanzíbar
[Música]
veremos qué pasa este año con el
resultado electoral efectiva pero amigos
el descontento de la población local va
en aumento y no podemos olvidar que
hablamos de una población musulmana
mayoritariamente joven con un desempleo
creciente por el bajón del turismo ante
la pandemia y que se ven oprimidos por
las autoridades tanzanas vamos en
definitiva todos los elementos
necesarios para que prospere el
extremismo islamista queridos amigos la
verdad es que no nos gusta contaros
estas cosas de tanzania cuando aseguró
que no se es un país maravilloso con el
serengeti o el manjar así que bien haría
un full y en rebajar su autoritarismo
antes de convertir un país que estaba
dando los pasos correctos hacia el
futuro en una tanzania aislada pobre y
convertido en su cortijo particular pero
llegados a este punto ahora turno para
ti y hoy vamos con una pregunta clave
consideras que debería de producirse una
presión internacional más fuerte ante el
presidente es así o piensas por el
contrario que es mejor no entrometerse
en los asuntos internos de otro país
amigos déjanos tu respuesta aquí abajo
en los comentarios y ya sabes si este
vídeo te resulta interesante
no olvides darle al botón de like
suscribirte avisar politics si aún no lo
has hecho un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]